et on a ce soir avec nous sofiane et
julie alors sofiane vous étiez liev de
sa meule pâti l'an dernier j'étais en
seconde merci d'être là ce soir en tout
cas merci beaucoup
comment comment tu te sens aujourd'hui
ça va on a un peu choqué donc bonjour
toujours c'est normal vous chagrine
c'est dans la ville
donc c'est choquant sa marque encore
vous avez été donc tu as été il est l'un
des élèves de monsieur pâtit ce que tu
peux nous parler un petit peu lui c'est
un profil it est très proche de ses
élèves
donc il était super bienveillant avec
nous toujours là nous demander si ça
allait si on comprenait par exemple
pendant le confinement
on communiquait beaucoup par mail donc
il était il était super présent en gros
pour nous aider pour nous faire
comprendre les cours ils étaient prêts à
nous expliquer comment tu as été mis au
courant de ce qui c'était ce qui s'était
passé j'ai été mis au courant que
s'était passé quelque chose dans la
ville donc évitons voyez la police de
partout et c'est moi j'étais d or à ce
moment là donc je suis rentré chez moi
j'ai allumé les infos et j'ai vu que
c'était le professeur mon professeur de
troisième qui était qui avaient été
décapités à quelques rues de chez moi
donc au départ où on n'ya pas cru en
cette vision non ils se sont trompés de
personne c'est pas possible
personne ne s'y attendait tu as 15 ans
est ce que tu t'es dit c'est pas
possible de faire ça c'est incroyable
c'est tête et a été choquée forcément et
ses mauvais on a parlé avec tes parents
qu'est ce que vous vous êtes dit à ce
moment là on était choqués on se disait
donc ça veut dire que on peut plus
parler on peut plus s'exprimer
bassan que ce qui est des représailles
alors tu high-tech à la marche est bon à
la marche blanche qui était présent à la
marche blanche
j'étais présent comment tu appréhendes
le retour en classe la semaine prochaine
est ce que ça te fait peur est ce que tu
as envie au contraire d'y retourner pour
essayer de 2 voilà deux de poste voilà
deux voilà de reprendre on avait à dire
une vie normale même si ça va être
difficile
moi ça va vous je suis plus dans le jeu
plus dans l'établissement moi je suis au
lycée maintenant d'accord qui est je
mords impact et du coup mais je pense
que ça va faire du bien à beaucoup de
revenir en salle
c'est en parle avec les professeurs
d'extérioriser quoi la liberté
d'expression c'est important pour toi
oui je trouve que c'est important après
moi l'image
je peux comprendre que ça puisse choquer
mais ça a pris d'être de trop grosses
pour de trop grosses proportions
alors il ya julie qui était avec moi
aussi toi julie tête élèves de samuel
pâti cette année
oui en troisième pareil comment comment
tu te sens aujourd'hui est-ce que tu
arrives à vraiment avis avoir une vie
normale ou qui pensent toutes les
secondes comme nous bat choqué bien
évidemment parce que comme je lui dis à
des prochains mois ce genre de choses on
pense que ça arrive que dans les films
et du coup on ne revient pas en fait et
on n'en revient pas que ça soit arrivé
en plus à notre prof
un prof qu'on connaissait on avait même
dans la journée même à des heures près
en fait et c'est ça qui nous choque
c'est que personne ne connaissait avant
avant cet acte horrible et et nous on
savait vraiment qu'ils étaient samuel
pâtit tu l'aimais comme professeur oui
parce que c'est pour n'était pas en
niant y donner envie d'apprendre en fait
ils donner ses cours avec cette joie
d'apprendre aux élèves
sa matière et avec des activités en
groupe pour vraiment roubaix qu'on
s'amuse en même temps tout en apprenant
paris c'était vendredi dernier
ttt au moment où ça s'est passé enfin
quand tu l'as pris tu l'a appris comment
on était quand je l' ai appris j'étais
chez moi mieux avec des parents non
d'accord tout seul j'étais chez moi et
est donc belle des élèves de 2de
m'envoient des messages mais nanti c'est
vrai que c'est je dis non non c'est pas
dans le col et ça c'est pas vrai c'est
des fausses rumeurs duo réseau parce que
parfois il ya défaut d'information qui
tourne
et puis petit à petit je vois certains
messages qui me dit allume les infos
donc pareil j'allume la télé et là je
vois de plus en plus d'informations et
j'ai tilté en fait que mais que c'était
dieu
salut elle pâtit alors tu en as on a
parlé le soir
forcément avec des proches et la famille
oui comment tu étais à ce moment là
qu'est ce que vous a dit qu'est ce que
tu on dit et par an bah en fait encore
une fois ils étaient choqués mais mais
on savait que cette histoire on en avait
déjà entendu parler en fait et donc on
en avait déjà parlé dans les débuts on
va dire et du comprend quand vous avez
vu qu'il était menacé quand je vous
avais parlé au collège en avait déjà
parlé au collège avec tes parents
également oui vous disiez quoi ben on
pouvait comprendre en fait que ça
pouvait être mal pris
maintenant comme comme il nous l'avait
dit en cour parce qu'on m'avait on avait
abordé le sujet il nous avait dit que
c'était juste une caricature pour
montrer pourquoi et les gens avaient
réagi au moment des attentats charrier
le dos et et pourront nous montrer en
fait pourquoi enfin tout ce qui s'était
passé et que en plus me semble-t-il qu'à
ce moment là ya pas si longtemps ça
repart avec ça donc c'était encore plus
pour remettre dans l'actualité
tu as envie de retourner à l'école oui
et non pourquoi oui et non parce que oui
parce que je pense ça va nous faire
quand même du bien parce que ça va être
chaud quand enfin on a peur de retourner
en cours mais en même temps on a envie
parce que on se dit que bah déjà ça va
peut-être nous vider l'esprit mais en
même temps non parce que c'est dans le
collège et on va voir sa salle tous les
jours il avait salon on passe devant on
va savoir que c'était sa salle et du
coup ça va nous toucher a été
traumatisée par ce qui s'est passée ta
peur de passer dans sa salle de huy
après rome oui parce que je ne me vois
pas en fait par exemple en cours être
dans sa salle et voir un autre prof que
lui ma prof d'histoire en fait ouais
c'est qu'est ce que aujourd'hui tu tu
pourrais dire sur la liberté
d'expression tôt
pour moi avec tes mots de tu adores
c'est à 14 ans oui pour moi la liberté
d'expression je pense qu'on est libre de
s'exprimer en fait chacun est libre de
penser aussi maintenant ben je pense que
on peut tous pensé dans nos têtes et pas
forcément bas le dire chacun pense ce
qu'il veut en fait est qu'on n'a pas à
imposer ce qu'on pense aux autres et son
opinion parce qu'on a tous un opinion on
voit tout ce que les choses différemment
donc pour moi on doit être libre échange
et peut-être fait d'échangés ça peut
aussi oui aussi mais bart avancer les
choses pour moi la liberté d'expression
c'est la liberté de parler mes pensées
aussi librement
tu avais tu avais déjà vu un cours d'eau
sur la liberté d'expression est monsieur
pâtit oui mais pas celui où ils ont
montré la caricature est ce que tu te
rappelles de ce qui vous avait dit je me
souviens que ben on avait parlé du coup
on parlait des religions des différents
ouvrages de religion et et je me
souviens aussi qu'après le court il nous
avait dit sortez une feuille qu'une
prière décents et qu'on fasse un dessin
qui exprime par le dessin la liberté
d'expression et des différentes
religions et des origines nous disait
par exemple fait un dessin où l'on voit
différentes personnes de différentes
couleurs de peau pour montrer qu'on est
tous égaux vraiment bas dans ce contexte
en fait qu'est-ce que tu avais dessinée
toi
j'avais dessiné me semble-t-il une
planète et autour d'étape aux différents
pour montrer que peu importe de quel
pays où 20 de quel pays on est de quelle
origine bat on est tous pareils en fait
vous avez 14 et 15 ans tous les deux
qu'on voyait tout ça on voyait tout ce
qui se passe entre autres la crise
sanitaire convient entre ce drame
on a vécu vous êtes vous êtes inquiet
pour l'avenir social ok pour l'avenir je
pense pas trop à l'avenir j'essaie de
vivre au jour le jour donc j'essaie de
ne pas penser à ça vous que c'est
négatif à mon avis on voit que faire
quoi plus tard trois semaines moi je
travaillais dans le droit donc je sais
pas trop encore mais et etoy et les
sépare pas d'accord vous avez envie que
ceux qui le collège va peut-être
s'appelait
sa meule pâtit c'est vous allez défendre
cette idée
oui c'est un bel hommage c'est un bel
hommage parce que je pense qu'il faut
lui rendre hommage par tous les moyens
possibles c'est important